[Music]
thank you so much for having me
sorry
that was good i'm just excited
uh introduce yourself and the show
no i don't no do it you have to do it
thank you guys so much for tuning in to
another episode of just kidding news
everybody this is anthony our host
[Applause]
do you know what why you're on that
chair i'm a hottie i'm a hottie i'm a
hottie yeah man
yeah
you know what happens during hot seat i
i watched uh
an episode and which i think is hawk
oh yeah and then he was uh that was a
very lukewarm seat that wasn't easy oh
really can you do an impression of hawk
for us or i might
sorry i'm sorry don't worry the worst
impression the worst dude you guys are
all really good at impressions is the
best it's really cool i appreciate that
thank you
just do one
all right so what we do on hot seat is
we started off cold and we turn up the
heat and ask super super hot questions
but to start it off we want to go with
bart he's the he's the cold trendsetter
of it of it all i feel like you guys set
it up like this but really it's just
like whatever comes no he's really cold
oh really really oh that's right oh
that's really nice some people think
it's cold some people think it's hot i
think it's pretty hot i think that's
pretty spicy yeah all right so here's
here's the question for you
you gotta think really deeply about this
do you think
if you were blind
would you be able to tell the difference
between broccoli and cauliflower
that's your best one yet dude
i'm like
i don't think i can sorry jason
dude that's good man that was good
answer the question jason yeah
how oh wait what do you mean you're
blind right right so you don't know the
yellow i've never had it before i never
had it because you had it you had it
yeah but you guys could tell
because the green the broccoli is it has
a little
smaller
if you bite it it's like it falls out
they're like little seedlings
and cauliflower is like they bite it and
it falls out like a buffalo
the green stuff because that's how they
make cauliflower rice oh i see what you
i see what you say what do you say but
the but the cauliflower it's like
cauliflower doesn't have tips that like
it's more of a chunk of cauliflower
when did you think of this question
two
favorite questions he's got written down
wait do you ask everybody the same
question no he comes up with that one
special for you he was good that's so
nice you're inspired
you made a special one for me
i'm gonna turn up the heat a little bit
okay
um
how was it like telling your parents
that you're gonna be a stand-up comedian
i thought it was gonna be gradual
he watched the show dude
i think mine is a little bit different
i repeated the question your question
just to make sure that i understand it
good good good thank you because i am a
professional yeah yes
um i think it's a little bit different
than other comics they they just say no
immediately mine they didn't take it
seriously they said ah stupid that's a
funny joke
they say you are a good comedian well
you started already oh you start already
yeah until a little bit uh
until later like maybe
when i yeah when i
wanted to do a full time so you've been
doing it for the past four or five years
so they knew that you did this as a
hobby yes and then you're like i'm gonna
do it because they're like this is not
serious yeah and then what's common
they um what do they say oh no you're
not an engineer no they knew i was gonna
be an engineer oh
even as a kid that so they're kind of
just like i guess so they just kind of
reluctantly accepted it so they didn't
get mad and be like you had to be a
doctor or anything like that well they
gave that up early they gave up on me
earlier on so it was easier to
to do so they had no expectations for
you already not really kind of easier
yeah to be like okay
you know but not they didn't yeah but
they still i know that they want the
best you know for
for me you know but it's just um yeah
been the beginning oh i was gonna ask
you when you when you say you were doing
comedy full-time when you were doing it
part-time did you have another job that
you were yeah i did so i worked for my
family they have a manufacturing
business
and um that was the last thing that's
when i wrote my three things that i
really wanted to because i hated it so
bad they have a factory in china in
china yeah more than many what did they
manufacture so like um ski and snowboard
jackets and uh do they use children is
it called north face only only children
oh okay that's the brand name children
it's just me and my sister
two child you make all of north face
with your sister
yo can you hook me up with some
snowboarding clothes
yeah sponsor sounds reluctant yeah oh no
because now it's less now now it's less
it's like
hard yeah
now it's like less
uh business or what do you mean yeah
just less business yeah okay okay but
then yeah when you said that if you went
to amsterdam
your wife would let you bang a hooker
probably why why is she so like
open-minded like so cool
that's so chill she'll probably let me
do it but she wouldn't want um she
wouldn't want me to do it but if i'm
like hey i wanted to do it because she
knows that i wouldn't even want to do it
is the thing like i wouldn't want to do
that like honestly that that's why i
wouldn't that's me neither nina she's
gonna allow you because she knows you
wouldn't do it so bad i don't want to do
it but i just like if i said i really
wanted to she would have been okay with
it
what kind of a relationship do you guys
have like it's super open or like oh no
it says uh
i
i try to tell her everything like uh try
to be as honest as possible and if i
like earlier i was telling nick and
anthony that even when i
are attracted to other women i try to
tell her that i come in like i really
wanted to you know bound her yeah oh but
i didn't say that though but you said it
different way i say it differently i
said you know she has the organ and i do
too
if it comes together
anatomical [ __ ] yeah it's science
is it does it go the same way does she
tell you he has an organ and i do too
and if if we did these organs might
match like his organ wants to beat my
organ up just heat it up
[Laughter]
yeah no i wanted to respect her that's
already that i wanted to make jokes
about but i didn't want that i wanted to
respect her because she watches it too
but um i don't um yeah but she doesn't
say that she she really yeah she loves
me you know yeah okay well we'll you
know we'll get off of her for a second
we'll bring it back when it's hotter
okay
so she loves you so she won't say that
but you love her but you will say that
but but the thing is like why you gotta
[ __ ] me like
why is this seat on heaven why are you
gonna why do you gotta [ __ ] me right in
the face man yeah all right well the
thing is
guys is that uh
ladies and gentlemen
uh is that
we think we have different a little bit
different values and i think i could
speak uh for guys in general that
sex means a little bit les
it's different than emotional connection
it's a massage it's a massage
with your special organs it's an organ
massage
massage that's a good rebrand you guys
are saying that constantly together is
making me feel very uncomfortable it's a
massage it's a massage
it's misogynistic
okay
now we're getting somewhere i was ryan
level
no but i could be wrong you know i don't
know it's just our relationship yeah all
right so uh let's let's get into some
more quick weighted hot seat questions
just answer honestly because you're an
honest guy
i tried to be just don't think too long
is all okay well that's how my brain
works man i understand you have to give
you the right answer
you recently uh did did some stuff with
davidson right yeah honest honest like
attractive level skill on a scale of one
to ten what is david so to you
attractive level skill one to ten just
in general yeah attractive level
definitely good luck i'm gonna give you
a very uh accurate yeah accurate like
how hot do you think davidson is why do
you use
what this is hot season we're just
warming up so this is how we do the show
yeah that's how we do the show um how
attractive yeah like like how much would
you [ __ ] up like and you were to rate
him yeah one to ten honestly like i want
his dick or like i don't want his dick
type stuff you know
um
if he doesn't talk and just sit there in
like a library
[Music]
what 1.5 okay
what if he talks okay what if he talks
chatting up in the library a lot he's
chatting about that you're chatting it
up no 1.5 um no uh 1.6 no no no like
like i know we're doing decimals
like a seven like a
like a seven i feel like this is this is
my why did you say it three times he's
spelling it out he's trying to okay
that's his method i bet you see lulu's
loving this video this is the truth like
i really like personality it doesn't
matter how you look yeah no but you
can't be like
obese
do i mean but he lost a lot of weight i
was training david the other day and he
was wearing these barbell brigade shorts
yeah and his ass was looking fatter than
barbs bro wow and it was like it was
like supple and i was like god i was cat
calling him the whole time he's doing
squats
damn
you got to get him to start doing uh
barbell thrusts
that's what really helps huh yeah it's
going to be it's going to be crazy it's
going to be crazy if he doesn't barbell
okay so 1.5 if he's in a library just
sitting there
as long as he's not talking seven if he
what he said exerts personality yeah
personality is everything i think yeah
unless you um
are really unless you have a bad
personality
when you say that to your wife
does she take it as
you're not that good looking but your
personality is so amazing that's why i
love you if she says that to me no when
you tell that to her do you think she
takes it that way because you're like
i'm a personality
definitely not she goes like what are
you talking about you're skewed on
personality women is different though i
feel like they need to look good i think
they go i need to look good like women
they go they're not like okay at least
have a good personality they don't say
that they go
oh [ __ ] i need you know what i mean oh
so you're talking about judging guys i
think he's talking about them judging
themselves yeah
i feel like they can personally desire
to desire to look good yeah yeah yeah
exactly okay moving on from that how
about first impressions of uh just
kidding
um
for
news
sure yeah
sure yeah why why
this group of people this group oh this
group this environment when you first
came in what was your first impressions
first impressions or even our first
video where you think our first
impressions were yeah when did you first
see our first video it was a very early
one i remember it was like
youtube squatting down in front of a
garage i forgot what it was and it was
like a gangster thing
is that is that when i broke the crate
and and we were talking
and i was a gangster you was a gangster
for sure both of you real gangster tv
baby and it was like some some like and
something in the house with the fridge
ice cream i forget but it was yeah it
was then but until now you guys did
really different stuff i really like oh
but the crew you said um i think it's i
think it's nice i don't feel like you
guys give a [ __ ] a lot you guys you guys
are all professionals that obviously but
i think um it's really nice like it's
positive energy is the thing and it's
just like a
[ __ ] around touch each other's penis
energy
that's about right yeah that's kind of
we touch each other's dicks all the time
man it's crazy yeah especially over
there that's like that's the cop corner
our hands are always down here just
we're always giggling but the thing is
like i feel like it's so nice that you
guys built a thing from that thing until
now you get to do this because i don't
feel like a lot of people i don't think
anybody could just do this thing and
have like
uh
like a lot of people watch it yeah you
can't just come [ __ ] around like what do
you mean like we just talking about fish
like what is happening
news that's not news you know what i
mean
you guys get to do this it's so cool
but i know obviously
he's playing a [ __ ] saxophone thing
for two seconds like who does that
mean that's so nice
it's the best and you guys are so
talented seriously all of you guys is so
cool yeah but but you guys it's so nice
to build like a thing
from that thing to be able to do this
that's the coolest [ __ ] wow that's
awesome this guy's so nice he's throwing
off my questions in my mind i'm like
would you rather [ __ ] your mom or your
dad but like after you said something
i'm like i shouldn't ask that right i'll
win all right
my mother
it's the truth because it was the how
you said it that was crazy yeah yeah no
sorry i did it take two thank you guys
all right would you rather [ __ ] your mom
your dad my mother
oh dang it double down by the way most
people have picked dad i know because
they're because because they don't want
to admit that they were attracted to
their mother not all of them or they
might not be but my mom's gross your
mom's pretty hot she's okay
even more stay tuned take two
months
no of course not but if i have to choose
from my mother or my dad i don't want to
[ __ ] my dad
because there's [ __ ] inside number one
and he's probably going to be very angry
so i'm going to have to be my ass after
i'm mad at the answers it's very logical
well you you mentioned earlier that you
you mentioned earlier that you came to
america on your own
are you a parachute kid what does that
mean that means your parents threw you
off of a plane on a parachute and then
they say bye-bye become american citizen
and then they come join you later pretty
much
oh
i didn't know that was a turn yeah it is
it is it's kind of derogatory a little
bit toward uh
i'm offended yeah you're welcome you
should be yeah this is the thing yeah
and when i went to the public school um
i didn't
like cool asians wouldn't want to hang
out with me man why i wouldn't i was so
sad oh damn because that was a fob
i still wear monday what's considered a
cool asian teeth just they were born
here and then they you know like you
[ __ ] man
[Laughter]
we're hanging out with you
here no but i had an accent and i was
like kind of
i was more fobby you know you don't want
it i know like it's just culture is
different so you guys hang out with and
then they go yeah but this guy is you
know
oh yeah but so when you first how many
years that you lived here by yourself
until your parents came quick it was
like two and a half wow and then yeah
and then they came and two and a half
two and a half months or a week years
old because after our that's when you
went to the military school so you could
just live there yeah i lived there yeah
it was nice come out he said it was nice
it was because you just it's a nice
school if you do nice things but at the
same time it was [ __ ] wild in them it
was wild but that was the fun part yeah
is that you could the freedom yeah the
jizz and everything
dude my friend would like jizz on
the uh like
put the captains or whatever their
pillows and stuff and what and then
they'll sleep and sometimes he will put
like
pews pubes
in his mouth
when he's sleeping
yeah that was that was the fun part you
enjoyed and we would we would jerk off
together we bonded wow so you had a true
circle we weren't looking in each
other's eyes yeah so no circle jerk
so it's like you're sleeping but on
other sides of the bed going like this
yeah but we would put like a towel down
and then you jerk off that side i joke
off this side and when we're done we
high five
do you try to sink it do you try to try
to finish at the same time i go are you
close
and he goes not yet and i'm gonna go
okay
and then i uh
i wait a little bit
well that's the thing like people that
that's why people can come together the
couple's gay or not no try to sink you
want to think it you got to wait you
can't be too eager yeah yeah that's real
love making that's what i'm saying and
they go i'm ready and i go me too let's
go yep that's a routine honestly you
stroked it a little
to to prepare interesting and when
they're ready you go okay and then you
try to shoot at the same
and time you're going yeah we go
yeah do you miss that
with your friends sometimes
do you miss them sometimes yeah we do
that
specifically
that tells you when we specifically it's
a
a
yeah
what was like your favorite thing about
america when you first got here
uh favorite thing about america
um i i had to learn what it is first but
that was the first time eighth grade
summer is the first time i smoked weed
and i think it does the free i didn't
even know what freedom was because my
whole life i worked uniforms you know
and then just did you know school and
all this so when i first came here it
was just like
it's more free and i didn't know what
like oh you could do stuff like you
could like
not listen to teachers all the time
[Laughter]
no from taiwan was it like the teachers
would hit you and stuff every day they
did
they would be very rare if they they
didn't they just hit you for no reason
no because i was acting up in it
but but also if you have bad grades you
line up and then they they it's like the
korean movie is the same thing yeah yeah
but so it's so nice is that you came in
and people they just let you fail in
peace exactly
they tell you to go march and it's like
that's really nice too because you get
to walk outside walk outside there's
fresh air that's true
you know grass he's just living a normal
life and he goes
freedom
it sounds like you're in north korea and
[ __ ] dude that's why it's good it starts
but when your life starts shitty yeah
and then when you see normal you're like
ah it's heaven
[Laughter]
perspective change what is one of the
more severe diagnoses your therapist
told you you have they they there's no
other diagnosis or issues do you have
like they didn't tell me one they didn't
they just said come back every week what
their they i think a psychiatrist could
diagnose you maybe i don't i'm not sure
but therapist is just to make you feel
better and try to figure out what you
want to fix so they'll tell you oh maybe
try this
like conditioning with yourself and then
and then try to be happier or whatever
the thing was was there a catalyst for
why you decided to go see a therapist
um
yeah so during the pandemic i was uh
i wanted to be a physical therapist
because i didn't i couldn't do comedy
and i was really sad oh [ __ ] and i was
playing diablo hey nice
the third one diablo i forgot the number
but
but it was really good though it was a
good one
and uh i was
i was upset
so then i i have to see you like this
guy
i don't know what you thought of my life
we need like five more hot seats with
this guy
you're the most fascinating person that
we've had in here
is that good yeah that's good yeah and
then uh due to therapy
because i
and other comics made fun of me after
like couple months ago i was like yeah i
was thinking seeing that therapy he's
like what are you [ __ ] kidding me
because they don't take you seriously if
you [ __ ]
because you got to die for man you can't
[ __ ] be trying to change another
career and um
but yeah but i really want it because i
said i was like man this is my only
thing that i because really that's the
longest career or job that i held and
one thing that i was sacrifice anything
for is stand up because i didn't i was
never good at a thing
and i always wanted to find a thing that
i'm good at but it was never good enough
even if i was
good at it you know
i wasn't good at it
but uh yeah that's why i wanted to stand
up i just wanted to do
be
happier and
have tools to
navigate situations or
better you know because i want the tools
i would apply them that helps man yeah
that's very good thank you sorry
no no no no no no this isn't your name
is not hilarious we're [ __ ] laughing
a very very unique talent of expressing
honesty yeah i don't actually
take anything of what you're saying as a
joke except for the ones that i
hopefully think are clearly jokes yeah
but other than those you have a really
good way of being honest you want to
make out i'm telling you it's
fascinating see that's see i don't know
when it's a joke but i like it
everything is more exciting with you
sydney well i try to be i try to be
truthful because it feels better on the
inside and that's that i think that's
really good advice too is like being
good at a skill is the best
like method to have good self-esteem
anything anything because i have the
lowest self-esteem like earlier in
another episode you guys were asking
like oh did you feel
looking good or whatever like i never
thought that i never thought that yeah
as boys we all think you're good looking
dude well you're very good at comedy
you're good stand up and you're good
looking so like if you were quiet in a
library not saying a single word
guaranteed over 1.5 to me dude
if i had if i had if i had your body in
your face i already [ __ ] a lot but i
[ __ ] even more
i hope you receive many tits of
admiration in your vms
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you